Once again, here's the design
we're looking to create.
What's great about this view is that
it uses mostly UI elements we've seen
before.
In order to prevent the number
of complex layouts from growing
explosively, we're going to
take advantage of three Android
layout features.
The first one we've seen before.
The only difference between
a forecast list item on the phone and
on the tablet is padding and
margins around the list items.
Fortunately, it's easy to add
this to the forecast list.
We can use dimensions to give the same
layout more space in tablet layouts.
In forecast list item layout, we can add
a padding dimension to the outer layout.
We use padding here instead of margin
because we just want the content in set.
If we used margin,
the row selector wouldn't be drawn
across the entire list item.
We also use a different dimension for
the space between the two temperatures.
Note that we use both right and
end to make sure that this layout is
ready for right to left mirroring.
So then in our resource's file we
create a dimension that updates
the extra padding and
the space between the two temperatures.
And that layout is updated.
I'm using sw600dp-port.
Which means that these changes will
only be applied Portrait Orientation
with devices and a view sides
with at least a width of 600 dp.
The second thing we take advantage of
is Layout Reuse using the include tag.
We can see that our portrait and
landscape detail fragment
use the same views.
The fragment detail view contains
these included lay outs already.
Note that we can assign new lay out
parameters when we include the lay out.
We're not using this in sunshine.
But we can avoid adding an extra
container when we include the layout by
using the merge tag in
the layout to be included.
Finally, we're going to
continue to make use of Refs.
Refs allow us to make aliases for
resources.
As you can see,
in tablet landscape mode,
the detail view should point to
a vertical version of the view.
We're going to create a Ref that
points to fragment_detail_start and
make sure that it points to the correct
detail fragment for all configurations.
This will come in handy
in the next lecture.